on Wednesday night over Indiana the
rematch against Paul George's former
team nice cut by karl-anthony towns of
Kepler finds up for the duck to that
direction to force him that way you
susceptible to setting screens and power
towns makes a typical shot underneath
the
Steven Adams preaching about eleven
half-shot temps the first two games they
said you gotta be you and then he got
the shots up against Minnesota
karl-anthony towns beautiful right hand
jump hook and called Bob Fitzgerald went
to go and state warriors that's how much
research I did I actually called
somebody and talked to him on the phone
Fitz gave me a little bit of insight
into you know how the organization is
can on the glass against the Pistons on
Wednesday night two bowls come up with
another stop and then cat nearly turned
it over Butler to win games so he gets
it he makes Russell miss blocks the shot
but then got to take care of the
basketball
someone's got a rotate back and give
Townsend outlet Butler County back here
at this quarter Westbrook changes
direction and it gets it blocked by
towns with the putback by Adams staff
and they had five of the roller it's a
start Carly any timeouts quickly great
so you talk about finishing at the rim
he's proven that he can do that
consistently towns quickly off the feet
from Butler T five past four times that
was pretty bad that's a reverse wedge
then he goes out to set the weight pick
for jump Teague and then the roll the
corners empty so there's nobody to pick
up the roller that time it's kion Steven
Adams scored on that one play as well to
hand off his decision and you know I got
so many different answers from suddenly
different people today that they thought
[Applause]
to point [ __ ] good his foot was just
barely on the line towns sticking with
it towns gets it to go
[Applause]
Raven goes on school biased Jones trying
to score it sets a cat for the foot back
[Music]
[Applause]
she blocked my towns that block number
for tonight he's playing away a little
bit defensive game here tonight
while Robert a lie